the major part of the livestock market
in Europe consists out of pig meat veal
and beef with 150 million pigs and a
yearly production of about twenty two
million ton carcass weight the EU is the
world's second biggest producer of pig
meat after China the EU has a bovine
heard of around 87 million and a total
yearly production of about 7.5 million
tonnes of beef farmers are in the street
because the livestock sector and the pig
meat sector in particular are having a
difficult time we produce too much in
relation to what is either consumed or
exported to third countries experts are
badly affected by the prolongation of
the Russian ban on European agricultural
products by restrictions linked to fit a
sanitary problems african swine fever
for instance and internally it's true we
consume less pig meat because of
changing eating habits pig meat beef and
veal belong to the agricultural products
for which the EU provides market
instruments to stabilize the livestock
sector when needed ministers are
gathering this Monday to assess the
situation and discuss other possible
measures to be taken immediately to ease
the situation